sub
[Silence]
subh
before we
begin we ask Allah subhanahu waala to
give strength and resilience to our
brothers and sisters being absolutely
bombarded with
aggression being terrorized day and
night for over two months
now
their great sin or their great
transgression was but they refused to
leave their land and
refused to live a life of extreme
humiliation and
degradation and much has been said in
the way of
propaganda turning these people who
are being forced from their homes and
their homes literally being demolished
on their
heads a lot of propaganda is circulating
to try to convince the world that this
is not genocide this is
defense that their aggressors are merely
defending themselves they are merely
protecting their country quote unquote
merely protecting their citizens
Etc and
unfortunately we see
great loss not only in our brothers and
sisters who are enduring this but great
loss in the way of the rest of the
Muslim World those who have militaries
those who have treaties those who
have ability to leverage the situation
and they are standing by idle and worse
yet many of them
are actively backing this
terrorist genocide that is happening
before our eyes we ask Allah subhanahu
wa taala to keep our brothers and
sisters firm and resilient and to
strengthen them in numbers and in
ability we ask Allah subhanahu waala
that he grant them Victory and that he
make them a thorn in the side
of all those who stand against them we
ask Allah subhanahu waala to send down
His blessings and mercy and Tranquility
upon his people the people
of the people of the Blessed
lands around the third of the great
prophetic
[Silence]
mosques
We are
continuing our
discussion
regarding obviously our original class
is and we haven't strayed from that
class however as we've mentioned
before may Allah have mercy on him
sh the author of Z and
Islam
he wrote this book he authored this book
Z from memory it's an extremely
expansive book but due to the fact that
it was written from memory and it was
written during travel and of course
traveling I mean even on our time is
difficult and strenuous emotionally
taxing and taxing on the
body how much more so in his time he
was on his way to Hajj and obviously he
was residing in deash he was residing in
Syria and so Hajj at the time was an
intense Journey it was a journey that
took many months and is the reason why
we have three
consecutive sacred months in our
Islamic lunar calendar we have
or
and these three sacred months and
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala placed these
sacred months in this order so that a
person would have an entire month of
sacred of sacred safety on his way to
Hajj perform Haj in in the middle of
these three months and then have a month
of safety to
return and so on this journey he wrote
this book Z very strenuous Journey a
difficult
journey and because of the fact that it
was written from
memory there are aspects which he did
not completely
Encompass and there are also
aspects of the book that seem to be
out of order usually books are
written in a very particular
order which has been pretty much
agreed upon amongst the scholars of f
historically that they would Place
their books in a particular order and
this order isn't observed completely
there's a general outline which is stuck
to but but the chapters are a little bit
scattered the point here that we're
making is that in the
spirit of discussing all that has to do
with the prophet Muhammad s. wasam and
his times and his Sunan and his life and
his
biography in this Spirit it behooves
us to draw from other books which were
written on the subject in order to
complete
its in order to fully complete the
spirit of
what originally authored the book
in and so we are drawing
from authored
by and much of
what mentioned in parts of are taken
from or taken from similar sources we're
discussing the Miracles of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasam it's a topic that
honestly is overlooked by many Muslims a
lot of times we look at the miracles
of the Prophet Sall Al as kind of
fanciful things that occurred in his
time but we don't really sit and think
about the gravity of these Miracles the
gravity of the Moon splitting the
gravity of food which would barely be
enough for two people feeding a hungry
army during Famine of more than a
hundred people grown men and women
who were going through a time of famine
as we've mentioned before the
gravity of such a miracle and why that
miracle was given at that time Miracles
are performed by prophets not to bend
and
change the way that human beings live or
to bend or change the rules by which
those who inhabit this Earth must abide
by the natural laws that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala sets forth rather Miracles are
provided for a few reasons the first is
to prove the validity of the
prophets of any said prophets claim to
prophethood when they are able to say I
come to you from Allah and then Miracles
are performed this now is an
irrefutable
argument bolstering the validity of
said Prophets prophethood another
reason is to strengthen the hearts of
the followers of of these prophets and
so we see that these Miracles are
performed at a time that is
critical to the Disciples of the
Prophet Muhammad s. wasam not just with
fanciful miraculous Feats but rather
with things that were desperately needed
at the time whether that be food in a
time of famine or that'd be water in a
time of drought or that be rain in a
time of drought or that that be
Miracles that would not only Aid the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam and his
companions but be as well a
strengthening to their resilience and
hearts we can We are continuing in this
chapter trying to take it with
summarizing much of
what has mentioned however many of
these Miracles we have not heard of
before the average
Muslim who hasn't really studied and
grew up as a Muslim for instance many
of these miracles
are largely unknown to the masses of
the Muslims and the reason for this is a
lack of studying but the books of s the
books of Hadith they are filled to the
brim with these Miracles and many many
others has a very expansive book named
the
it's one of the most famous works
done and written by the scholars of
Islam on the subject is an extremely
expansive book in which he attempted to
enumerate all and any Miracles that were
narrated or performed by the prophet
sallallah alai wasam in his time or any
Miracles that occurred to any of his
followers because when a Miracle occurs
with the follower of the Prophet s.
wasam that Miracle is considered of his
miracles because it is happening to his
disciples which are an extension of
the prophet's
Legacy and so many miracles happened in
the time of the companions many miracles
occurred with Abu bak and om and Ali and
in their times many miracles occurred in
the times of the
and continue to sporadically and
sparingly occur throughout
time to Muslims around the world
they become more
they become more scarce the further
we travel from the time of the
Prophet s. wasam but nonetheless they
will always continue to occur for the
followers of Muhammad s. wasam because
there will always be as the prophet
himself has told us there will always be
a
group of the followers and the nation of
Muhammad s. wasam which will be clearly
upon the truth and they will be
protected from the harm of those who
attempt to Target them until the end of
time there will always be a collective
group of Muslims who are not only upon
the truth but know it and propagate it
clearly and those are the scholarship of
Islam throughout time and the bearers of
knowledge and those who implement the
Sunnah of the Prophet s. wasam as it was
intended they understand the Quran as
Allah intended they understand the
Sunnah as the prophet
[Silence]
intended
and subhanahu
waala
[Silence]
Allah
subh
[Silence]
the issue is not just that a person
believe in what Allah said or know what
Allah said it's not just that a person
believe or know what the prophet
Muhammad s. wasam said that's not
sufficient because words carry
meanings and that's the whole point of
words words are to be basically they
are vessels for particular meanings that
we articulate and so the point of words
is their meanings and
so Allah subhanahu waala Pres preserved
the
Quran but in preserving the Quran he
also preserved the proper understanding
of the Quran because those words that
are in the Quran could be understood in
many
ways and
most if not all
extremism and Innovation which has
occurred in the history of Islam it
occurs using the Quran
using the words of the Quran to
bolster these
Innovations why because they take the
wording of the Quran and give it their
own meanings they do not understand it
the way that Allah intended for them to
be understood they do not understand the
words of the prophet sallallah wasam in
the way that the prophet s. wasam
intended that they be
understood this is the true danger
because a Shan realizes he cannot change
the wording of the Quran he cannot
change the wording of the Sunnah of the
Prophet Sall Al wasam but the best he
can do is to change the understanding of
people who read the Quran and the Sunnah
and so there will always be a group a
ctive group throughout the of
[Arabic recitation]
s. and every time throughout the world
that will carry the words and meanings
of the Quran the words and meanings of
the sun of the messenger of Allah s.
wasam it's not enough to merely have
a verse to know a verse of the Quran to
know a narration of the Prophet Sall Al
wasam
we have to also understand these
Revelations as Allah intended as
a famously stated I have I believe in
Allah and in all that which has come to
us from Allah in the way that Allah
intended and I believe in the messenger
of Allah and all of that which has been
narrated to us and
transmitted from the messenger of Allah
in the way that the messenger of Allah
s. wasam intended this meaning is where
the rubber meets the road this is the
spirit of the difference between right
and wrong that we not only have the
words but we have the meanings and so
Allah will always preserve those
meanings for
us continuing where we left off last
last
week we had
reached we had reached
to was going through the various
Miracles he started with the miracle of
the
Quran
Quran and now we tells us may Allah have
mercy upon him that as for enumerating
the
Miracles which were performed by the
prophet sallallah and given to him
aside from the Quran it is not possible
for us to completely Encompass all of
them and to completely know all of them
meaning for any one individual person
it's they are too numerous too vast
too many for one person to know all
of
them meaning to write all of them in
a book books have been written on the
subject and that's not the point of the
book that we are reading this is merely
a chapter
therein
[Silence]
subhah
he says that the reason we can't
mention every single every single
prophecy and every single Miracle is
because these Miracles are incredibly
numerous and they are continuous and
they are increasing we said continuous
and increasing why because everything
that occurs to the followers of the
prophet sallallah wasam of
miraculous nature these are
considered of the Miracles of the
Prophet Muhammad sallallah alaihi
wasallam because they're happening to
those who carry his
legacy he said rather we will briefly
mention some examples and some instances
of the most famous and wellknown of
these
Miracles such as the Moon being split in
Mecca before we discussed
this also the instance when water was
made to gush forth from between the
prophet sallallah
fingers and give
when Allah subhanahu waala gave the
Prophet The Miracle of increasing the
water during a water shortage and a
journey that he was
upon and likewise
food and likewise that the food F that
he would eat
occasionally murmurs
of of exaltation of Allah would be heard
from this
food likewise the tree which was heard
to SB over the departure of the
Prophet sallallah alai
and a stone which was known in Mecca to
be heard to be conveying a Salam to the
prophet
sallam when he would pass it
[Silence]
by
she was asked when and also the food
that was given to him once which was
poisoned by a
Jewish this poisoned food was made for
him and he and some of his companions
sat down to eat it
and when they when he went to eat it he
had a mouth
full the food informed him that it
was tainted and so the prophet sallai
wasallam spit this out and some of his
companions passed away
now they died as a result of this
poison and the Prophet sallallah alai
wasallam asked the cook why did you do
this she said I figured I'd poison your
food and if you are really a prophet
it's not going to kill you it's not
going to harm you and if you are not
then people will be rid of you and we
mentioned the story last
week
[Silence]
and he tells us another miracle of his
was a tree that was made to become uhu
animate and it walked and was heard to
speak this was in Mecca before hij
likewise an instance where the
companions saw two trees merged together
in order to conceal him while he
relieved himself in journey of his
and then they returned to their place
this is referring to a narration inah
Muslim
J
[Silence]
s
this is a reference to a narration in
sah Muslim in which jab was accompanying
the prophet Sall wasallam on a
journey and he said I went with him to
be there with him and to serve him as he
relieved himself the prophet Sall Alam
went to an area and jabber said there
was a boulder there and so I sat behind
the boulder to give him
privacy and there were two
trees and neither one of these two trees
on its own would provide adequate
concealment while he relieved himself
and give him that level of privacy that
he is that is befitting of him and so he
said I looked over this Boulder and
peaked and I saw him holding the
branches of these two trees and I
watched him as he walked and these trees
walked along with him they came together
and he relieved himself he said I peaked
over the boulder after I figured he
was finished and I found that the two
trees had returned to their original
places a person may hear these
things and
think this
is you know this is something that is
very fantastic something
that's it's a miracle but it
seems almost unbelievable
and that is the difference between the
believer and the
disbeliever the dis the believer trusts
Allah and his
messenger the believer understands that
Allah subhanahu waala
created this world and its laws and he
is the only one with the authority to
break those
laws we should never be in a situation
and our journey to
Allah in which we find ourselves
standing
waiting for an
explanation of how these things occur
before we accept them and believe them
these are things that we can understand
how if we understood how they wouldn't
be Miracles anymore that's the nature of
a miracle the nature of a miracle is
that it's inexplicable it's
unexplainable we don't know how this
happened but we do know that Allah
subhanahu waala
occurred allowed and
decreed that these things
occur and this is how we know that our
messenger Muhammad s. wasallam is in
fact a messenger of
Allah if this were not the case how
would we know
a messenger from a liar how would we
know that this person is a messenger how
would we know that these things
occurred and there that that these
things that he tells us are from Allah
subhanahu waala the only way we can know
is if things that can only be done by
Allah are done for us to see and we see
them and we believe and when we believe
we do not
hesitate because aan and his followers
will constantly
attack the
believer and try to make a person feel
if you believe in that stuff you
know you're very weak-minded only the
feeble-minded will believe in things
like
this when in fact it is the
feeble-minded who believes that they
know what can and cannot happen it is
the
feeble-minded who believes that
everything that occurs they should be
able to understand it and if they don't
understand it then it's not real this is
this is very silly that is
feeble-minded and this
belief is also based on a type of faith
is it not for
instance is is it possible for these
things to have
happened let's say Allah subhanahu waala
if he had truly sent a messenger and
this messenger was from Allah and he is
the creator of these laws that this
world must abide by is it possible for
him to make these things happen the
answer is yes it's possible
right and so so the question
is if it is possible and we've been
informed by those who are trustworthy
and informed in a way that is something
that we can't reject why would we deny
it and a
the absence of evidence does is not
evidence of
absence
the absence of EV evidence is not
evidence of absence this is a logical
principle what does it mean it means
that just because I don't have evidence
that
something happened does it mean that it
didn't it's not evidence clearly that it
didn't happen or just if because if I
had I don't feel I have adequate
evidence for the existence of something
doesn't
mean that it doesn't exist just means I
don't know about it that's all it means
nothing more
right and so
disbelief and listen to this point here
because the idea and we've all heard
this before correct we've all heard the
idea that if you believe that you
know wolves talked and the moon split
and these things happen then this is
very feeble-minded right it's only the
simpletons that will believe in
this this is the idea it's to make you
feel small and to make you feel
ashamed that maybe you're being fooled
maybe you're gullible and nobody wants
to be that
person and
so people try to reject these
things rejecting it based on the idea
that this goes against the laws of
nature as we know them and this is
something that I didn't see with my own
eyes etc etc but here's the
issue that reject
ection is based on a type of Faith as
well is it not if a person
says that he does not
believe that the prophet Muhammad
sallallah alaih wasallam was a prophet
he doesn't believe that
right to make such a claim now you have
to explain away 1500 years of History
and thousands and thousands of verses
and
narrations of a legacy of 23 years now
you have to explain that if he was not a
prophet then what do we do with all
these things where did the Quran come
from how was he the way he was and not
just how was he the way he was but look
at his
followers and this is not a normal thing
a person who starts a cult doesn't end
up with three three and four billion
followers at any given time throughout
the world a person sitting in a little
mid in the middle of nowhere literally
in the middle of the desert in the Arab
peninsula how can this person
hope that his words will even reach
outside of this desert yet he says in
that mid in the middle of the this vast
desert he says says to his companions
during times of poverty he
says this religion will reach wherever
day and night reach meaning all over the
world and this religion will remain
until the end of time and the followers
of this religion will continue to
increase exponentially until the end of
time and make these kinds of claims
person can make those claims but 1500
years later
we see that that is the case and you
look at the
followers of Muhammad s you find them
the most devout followers even the the
one of weak faith those who we consider
to be weak in faith amongst us they have
in themselves a a strength of belief
that is unmatched it's an Empire of
Faith that's lasted for 1,000 500 years
and continues to
increase how do you explain that what do
we do with that if he was not a prophet
what how do we explain something like
that do we have another example another
instance in history that that this
is something that naturally occurs men
come out and make claims of prophethood
and they're all lies but these things
continue and endure through thousands of
years years and billions or trillions of
people throughout
time the most strong intellects that
Humanity has ever seen or produced are
the most devout of Believers in this
prophet and messenger how do you explain
that
away you were to say this is this person
is not a messenger Muhammad is not a
messenger now you have given us more
questions than answers that doesn't
solve anything makes everything more
complicated now because how do we
explain this this
phenomenon it's
unexplainable the only explanation and
that is that he was a messenger and
whatever comes to us from that messenger
we believe in it we believe in
it he tells me that an animal spoke
he tells me that an ant spoke he tells
me that the sea was split he tells me
you know the Quran tells me that the
moon was
split and
shame is the relative of those who
reject this they're the ones who are
that are to come up with an explanation
explain themselves not the believer the
believer doesn't have to explain himself
it is the one who lays claim to
disbelief he is the one who has to
explain himself now he is the one who
needs to come up with a proper adequate
reasoning that is not based on pure
desire why this person cannot be a
messenger we will stop there
inshallah for this evening continue next
week
[Silence]
allb